[Music]
[Applause]
everybody's a fan of the Rocket Man
that's what's going on yeah this is what
happens when Kate hasn't asked for
friends to come over and hang out well
that gets fair nated with Elton John and
if you're lucky a butterfly filter it
all equals fun yep Kate and we know that
she's expecting her third child a girl
this time and if Kate wants to know
what's in her baby girl's future or her
love life alone she's known to enlist
the help of psychic to the stars
Jane Wallace Kate Hudson she's now
pregnant do you think that they'll get
married I think yeah truthfully a future
Mario moon she'll probably have another
one with him I think this man's
different he's a soul mate her twin
flame so I think the future looks really
good
aside from Kate Jane says she's done
readings for Kim K she sees politics in
her future
there's also Leslie Mann and Larry King
as a psychic Jane connects with a
person's aura and then reads what's in
their future Nick Jonas Priyanka Chopra
[Music]
so the Empress is generally called a
fertility she wants to be a mom and she
wants a family
I feel I did I'm gonna say twins all
those two very close together also in
the cards of Jonas a secret wedding in
the Maldives or a beach somewhere
but for Ariana and Pete's Jane thinks
they'll have intimate Church I Do's not
a small wedding but a wedding that's
quite plain Jane thinks Justin Bieber's
not as invested as Haley Baldwin and
that big wins relationship is more about
lust than longevity what do you mean
what advice would you give them at this
juncture enjoy the list okay do you see
them walking down the aisle I think if
they did I'm not sure if it would last
they probably will do it for a public
viewing
Jane psychic sister shop in London is
now open in LA says Prince Harry and
Megan will have a baby boy and soon to
be honest we've been I would say the
next year I think she were pregnant
quite quickly they're actually really
strong couple now Kevin if you are
looking to get a reading from Jane
she says that anyone can comment she's
accessible but there is a waitlist
around four to six months and that is
just in her hometown of London you know
playing there you go she's doing
something right
[Music]